self
sorrow garvey i'm here with the lovely
pearl who is currently taking over the
internet okay she's taking the
manosphere by storm
and you guys already know that if you
have watched two or more of our videos
and you have not subscribed
then we got beef beef okay beef beef so
you better subscribe um today's episode
is
does society care about men
but before we even get to it
well
okay first off guys i want to say thank
you for 200k
[Applause]
guys um i could not do it without all of
you i really appreciate all of you
subscribing the last couple of months
the support has been tremendous but
while we're at it if you want to support
even more sign up for our memberships
that is going to help us pay rent the
next year so sign up for up for our
membership is going to help us upgrade
the studio um on top of that we have a
facebook page and a twitch page um that
we just started and go follow my
instagram it's just dot pearly things
um also on the memberships and the 10
tier we have two vlogs if you want to
see some behind the scenes content and
you also get to be a part of the
memberships or a part of the chat the
second half of the show also
if you want to super chat today we are
working to get issue camera
yes ma'am indeed should be coming soon
soon very soon very soon um
and all your super chats will be read so
fantastic today we have a lovely panel
um why doesn't everyone go around
introduce yourself say your name your
age your relationship status
and where you are from and you can start
my name is saya um i'm 34. um i'm in a
relationship
and what was your was that where are you
from um from london
hi everyone
my name is martine i'm 30 years old um
relation
relationship status i'm
i was gonna say
i'm engaged okay recently engaged
i don't know why it took you so long to
remember that i actually oh let me see
the ring let me see okay yeah okay hope
he's not watching think conditioning
yeah
um
okay and um i'm from essex
hiya i'm sally talks
okay hear me sorry hiya i'm silly talks
i'm 35. i am single and from london
cool
my name's murray
i'm 43
and i'm from kensington london
so guys and girls we're going to start
off with a quote everyone knows a
comedian called chris rock right
yeah chris rock said
women
children
and dogs
are loved unconditionally
men are only loved when they can provide
something
what do we think about that
are men only loved by condition
oh totally 100
i think it's
it's part of the journey for a man to
understand that when you beca when
you're transitioning from being a boy
into a man
and realizing that it's like the
unconditional love and acceptance you
get from your mum
is not shared by the rest of the world
and then you know it's about that
struggle to
understand you know it's not necessarily
going to come
you know i can't put it you you're going
to get love but only based upon the
value you can create for yourself
and that's it
you know when i've seen guys who don't
get that or they're caught in this
delusion
or they're not getting you know
they've not had that basis of
preparation from like their parents
they really struggle they really
struggle as as
developing into men because you know you
need that
self-reliance because if you're walking
around in the world
wait wanting to feel that unconditional
love
then you know you you've got a long wait
you've got really long weight as a man
do you feel like men
aren't loved
or is there um stipulations to a man
being saying not loved
are there stipulations to a man being
loved
yeah i mean i i don't think that um
women really love men like that you know
i mean there's always a condition
there's definitely always a condition to
it you know i mean um
i think that
you've
when you when you grow up you learn this
like very quickly
you learn this very quickly i think um
when you look at your your uh
the relationships from
um
like uncles aunties and things like that
and then you look at the relationships
between you like your your mother and
father you can instantly see this do you
know what i mean
and i think the reason why a lot of uh
men are
a lot of relationships break up
or even marriages break up
is be most of it's to do with financial
most of it's financial reasons
so that should show you that a lot of
the time
you know so bro guys don't deserve love
well
i think i think i think
i think women want to love they want to
love you but it's just they if if you're
looking at it from a nature standpoint
they just
can't they just can't do it after a
certain they just after a certain time
if you're not
providing you're not showing that you're
you're you know you're
on job you're on point then you know
it's is something in them just it just
clicks off
lady
do you want to go first yeah
so i've just i've been thinking this
quite a lot
and some of it something you said was
like you know oh you said that after
your mum like no one else speaking to
the mic sorry that after your mum no one
else is going to love you
unconditionally
that's what i'm thinking isn't that only
people that i love you unconditionally
is your parents is your mum and dad like
why why do you expect anyone else to
cover us as unconditional as well i mean
yes granted your your partner your kids
should but they're always going to have
like qualms with you
and i so i feel like i don't know
cases and i could be wrong where women
are left unconditionally
like you know in in my opinion
so i think that only people are gonna
love you is your parents now for that
it's the world and not gonna love you
unless you've got something well the
thing about
like a woman can do nothing and a man
will love her
like she can just exist
where sorry where whereas like men have
to become so they have to get good at
talking to women they have to understand
how we operate they have to learn how to
make money they have to learn
all these different things in order to
attract deaths where women can just
exist isn't that
isn't that a fault of a man not having
enough standards so if we are putting a
standard of i'll have to a b and c for
me to love you but because men say i
don't care about her money i don't care
about what she does anything i want to
take whatever girl i want that's a them
problem not necessarily like a society
problem because
like if you if you want to grab someone
from doing nothing that's kind of on you
really so i think it's more well it's
like when when men meet a new girl right
and they say to the boys i've met a new
girl and the boys say what does she look
like
right
when
women meet a new man
when we say i've met this new guy you
guys what does he do
it's totally different so women want to
know what this guy can do
and men want to know what she looks like
i think we asked both i was pretty like
what'd he do yeah i think always what
you look like first because you need to
know what it looks like then it's like
oh what did you do but it's very
important in in a woman's conversation
what he does that i don't i don't think
that's i don't think that's true you
wouldn't ask what he looks like yes i
would yeah
what does he look like go on what's up
show me his picture hundred percent yeah
no i i'd say that well i'm not obviously
i'm not a girl but i do your initial
though would it be the first thing you
ask yes yes for me what do you look like
well you know women women are
different in 2022 where they almost rate
men the way that
like men used to rate women
where they they value looks higher than
they ever have because of the
development of birth control where
before like they had to prioritize other
things because they had the risk of
getting pregnant so they couldn't just
sleep with the hot guy
but now like women put looks higher
because they can't they have birth
control so they can sleep with the
hawkeye even if he's not going to stick
around
yeah or before it was more like beta
like beta is that working for us to say
a woman put in a man's looks sorry his
looks over what he can provide
definitely won't
yeah it won't work it's not that's
that's why we say broke men don't
deserve love that's the whole point of
the campaign is like
we don't think it's enough so no
so then would you would you say fat
chicks don't deserve love on the same
token
i mean look someone's gonna love a
homosexual someone's gonna love a fat
chick so you know someone's gonna get
theirs no no not not for men though
because like most historically one out
of three men didn't reproduce
and i think it's actually less than that
i don't know the exact number but 80 of
women reproduced historically i think
it's 40 of them reproduced historically
so women in general can always get love
from someone but men they can't but how
why do you define that as love like just
because they
had someone that could reproduce with
that doesn't necessarily mean they were
loved
because
what do you mean the women are the men
so the women
so you're counting love just by
reproduction right so you're saying
because women were able 80 of women were
able to reproduce that then means that
80 of women were loved well i'm saying
that there's always someone that's gonna
date a girl because a third of like one
out of three men haven't had sex in the
past year
or is a virgin under 30. so i'm saying
there's always someone like there you've
seen my 600 pound life yeah they all
have they all have boyfriends yeah but
it's not the same vice versa i i i think
a bright man can find love i mean the
campaign is not but
to say like i haven't heard stories
about a man moving in a man not working
a man not doing stuff but he's got a
girl by his side his friend his
lifestyle i'll be lying i've heard it
more than what but typically those guys
are hot
or they they're really good at talking
to women they have something they're
good in bed too honestly yeah they have
something that's keeping the girl in
there yeah there's multiple there's
there's different values i mean if it's
the conventional providing value like
he's got a good job that's one or good
income whatever there's one value but if
it's like
he provides emotional excitement and you
know whether it be him being toxic or
how he's gonna do that
then he can be broke i mean i know when
i was younger
i used to run nightclubs and i had no
money i just had a really good social
circle
i had access to whether it be drink
free dinners and all that stuff
i had those things
i didn't i wasn't really a good prospect
but it allowed me to have random give
get access
so again you because you could provide
something
you had access
yeah i had access before but that kind
of super like kind of turbo charged it
when i was like 19 20.
um
because that slogan broke men don't
deserve love like pearl was saying
if a slogan or a hashtag was like fat
women don't deserve love it would be a
thing
like it would be like uh there will be
an uproar you can't say that you're fat
shaming
what broke guys don't deserve love
we can make an encouragement song let's
encourage girls to hit the treadmill
it was the workout plan by kanye
yeah
he let you know if you work out you get
sleep and get your surgery you get the
money would you say would you say it's
equal well
would you say that there's equal equally
as many songs for women as there are for
men
of getting on the treadmill yeah
definitely not no definitely not but i
mean you know but i think right so
wouldn't you say that's more of an
exception a perception rather than the
rules if you're going by music you look
at you look at um
you hear the songs for women great men
don't deserve um girls right but then
you look at the
male
male videos or rap videos they saw
skinny
women so
yeah
women so i i mean it's very very i mean
if someone has a fat chick in the video
you're making a statement you're trying
to say something
regularly is just going to be a skinny
um beautiful instagram looking very
ambiguous i see i see fat models all the
time but so look at liz but men aren't
looking at yeah
but i'm saying it's catered it's catered
to women like victoria's secret they're
bringing in fat chicks this is supposed
to be the epitome of beauty they're
bringing in fatches that's because
they're realizing that other brands have
understood that the world is universal
not everyone is tall and skinny and they
accept that victoria's secret didn't
that's why now they're trying to jump on
the bandwagon but they're doing it for
their customers
yeah they're catering their kids yeah
they're catering to women
that's what i'm saying like everything's
about women yeah do you think women get
like
more see and to quote another um
comedian bill burr said that women's
issues are taken seriously you know
you've got
ribbons groups
all this kinds of stuff like numbers you
can call
um he actually cited a a thing that
happened in america where a wife cut off
her husband's penis
threw in a garbage disposal right
and he was laughing ah stumpy yeah and
he was saying well if a guy cut off a
woman's teeth and put it in a dryer
would would people be laughing about it
no absolutely not no that's disgusting
yeah well i'm just saying what he was
saying like women's stuff is taken more
seriously i think this is our over
correction by society in general i think
if you if you take it back
um
before women thought they had um
rights and things like that before that
time maybe it was before the 60s or
something because they thought they
didn't have rights yeah sorry
um
then it would have then
as soon as they've they've gained the
the backing from men and things like
that i think what men have done is
they've over corrected in society to the
point where it's tipped so much that now
it's almost like yeah
it's very clear
because
you know since women after the second
world war when more women joined in the
workforce and the buying power of women
so yeah you're gonna then slant all your
marketing and everything else
to that buying power you know
yeah and and it wasn't necessarily
corrected most when you're i think
you're talking about like the right to
vote and that sort of thing but most
people in history didn't have the right
thing about i think it's just more the
attitude the attitude was over corrected
so
uh but it's it's over corrected through
things like feminism which is
which is put
um instead where they thought that men
were above women they've suddenly now
put women above men and they haven't
actually made it where they thought they
were going to make it equal they've
actually put i would say that's a
misconception though historically i
don't think they thought men were above
women
yeah yeah that might not be that might
not be accurate that might not have
actually been accurate you know what it
is but i think that that's that's what
this is
feminism is just women want freedom
without responsibility
like even even with the right to vote
are we equally drafted for combat
situations no that's why we couldn't
vote
i agree
so like that's what feminism constantly
does is it wants more freedom but less
responsibility and so it's saying like
give us the freedom but not the
responsibility that comes with it
what do you think ladies are you
feminists me personally no
i am a womanist i'm not a feminist
feminist wasn't made created for me was
created for the white woman so
i don't necessarily want to delve into
when i was looking into it and say
resonate with me because if i was back
then those times i still don't be able
to vote i still wouldn't be seen as
human so
so what is it what is a womanist then
it's more catered around the black
female experience and the kind of
struggle that we
that we go for as black females and also
because in our culture in general like
for example in my culture i'm ghanaian
we have we have we
when we were growing up
but my tribe had ashanti worry warrior
women we had we had people we had women
that were heads of the phone but we
still serve their husbands so it's a
different kind of
um
concept of like oh if your woman is in
power they should must be submissive or
what have you so
that's why i say that i'm i struggle
with that through feminism because of my
culture my background who i am and as i
i
am mortgage towards womanism and stuff
i'm still learning about that stuff as
well so yeah
is there a right that you feel like
women don't have in 2022
i mean some rights have been taken away
and it depends what country you go to
and you know obviously in america have
just you know stopped
abortion
um before in saudi when women couldn't
women couldn't drive
and you know in some cultures when we
can't get this sorry i'm talking about
i'm talking about the west in the west
oh i mean just because we're in london
so yeah
yeah you know i mean i would say oh
look look by looking in you would say
we've got all the rights we need however
if you even look into because obviously
london is very diverse so you go into
the cultures and things like that like
you look at um child marriages
and
um young young women that are fought
into those things these are still that
already got changed recently to say 18
years should be getting married so
there's still some work on the ground to
do in regards to women and their rights
but definitely in the west women are set
are saturated with their rights
what do you mean there's this where
they've got too much rights they've got
loads that loads of rights i wasn't
i would say it's too many because you
know it's it's the privilege that we
have been in the west compared to
other countries that have that privilege
so i can't say it's too many but i could
i could definitely say
if you live in the west as a female in
some in some cultures you will feel like
you've got a voice where you can you can
talk but then
i think i think we have more rights than
man
but then you know but i also feel like
back to the question of men
a lot of industries are dominated by men
in this country so
why
ah why what do you mean i don't know why
well if you had to think if you had to
think about it
yeah why would you think that those
industries are dominated by men i think
because we live in a patriarchal society
where men are taught i honestly do i
feel like i feel by default okay so then
how are we in a patriarchy when there's
quotas that are specifically for women
that are encouraged to go in those
fields and not men and there aren't
quotas for men to go in female dominated
fields is this in the uk
everywhere
so so there's quotas say for like female
engineers where companies will say you
have to hire a certain amount of
engineers but say in the modeling
industry there's no quota for men
there's no equal pay for men or let's
say nursing
what men women get you know women get
paid more in this and i'm saying women
there are more women in the nursing
field than men oh so but there's no
quotas for men but there's special
privileges granted to women in male
dominated fields why is that it's a
patriarchy quotas for men but there's
more quotas for like
maybe black men
i don't even i don't know well like
affirmative action you mean yeah that
but i would
i think um reason the reason is because
when it's been dominated by men
now they have now because of all the
um equal rights and women go to work or
what have you they have to navigate the
quota but the quote is never going to be
more than the than the media
but i'm saying dominated by men what
which which give me an example of a
industry an industry there that you say
that's dominated by men television in
what sense what presenting and stuff no
like um like cameraman dops sound
you very really found a sound the sound
engineer you very really really get a
camera a camera woman so you think so so
i since i since i work and this isn't
television it's youtube right
but like i don't find girls want to do
those jobs
so like i i've i have ish and i have two
backup producers of ish isn't here
and they're all men and it's not because
i was seeking out like i didn't care i
just wanted someone that was you that
would do a good job and that's who
showed up so why is that a patriarchy if
they if a man and a woman has equal
opportunity at that job and there's just
more men that want to do it audio sucks
i hate do you think women are not
afforded the the opportunities
that men are in these kind of fields is
that what it is
well obviously um i would say to some
it's to some respect i would say
yes but like if you're an employer the
way i see if you're an employer and you
need to employ a man or a woman more
likely you're going to think as a woman
she's going to want to get married have
kids one day she might you know she's
going to have hormones in balance all
those kind of things you're probably
going to go for easy option with who is
a man rather than a woman i think and
those things come into play and what
women are trying to say in those things
that don't look at those things
treatment equals a man that gives the
best person the job but as an employer i
understand that you want so so that's
not
but i'm saying like i employ people and
i don't care i haven't played them no
but and i'm saying and i'm saying and do
you care
um
when i when i used to run a restaurant i
did care because i understood that it's
12-hour shifts
i need someone that's not going to tell
me their kid's sick do not mean so i
employed certain people men
was that is that you part of the
patriarchy yeah okay
no no but i considered it but because i
was a female i've quickly learned
i had to have a lot more females because
i listened to me more than the men so
then even what i wanted changed around
trying to train around me anyway and
that's what i noticed from working and
employing people
and
and so forth but again i think maybe you
don't i don't care because now and what
i do now because i'm i'm a woman and i'm
black i want the best part for the job
so i'm looking at all different kinds of
diverse people whereas i don't
necessarily think some sets of um people
are looking diverse because look like
that but i'm saying like i like my dad
my dad employed 250 people and he like
i'm telling you people don't care as
long as we make money i'm trying i'm
trying to get the cheapest employee that
will do the most amount of work that's
that's my goal
and so
and so it's like
like because if you don't do it that way
if you're not hiring based off of skills
then your competition is going to
outcompete you
i don't think we employ it by skills
though no but also equal opportunity
doesn't mean equal outcome do you know
what i mean so it's like if we employed
or if we if men and women
they've done it in the um in the
scandinavian countries they've said okay
cool this is the most egalitarian
countries we can find
men and women can go into all of the
fields then we are not we won't restrict
them and what happens is women and men
tend to choose different things
which is so when you're talking about
all these industries are um dominated by
men it's because men choose differently
from women and women choose differently
for men generally when it comes to jobs
like in the stem field science
technology engineering and mathematics
men are more likely to choose those
fields whereas women have the
opportunity to go into those so no one's
stopping women from going into those
fields
they just don't choose those fields and
where and where are the marches about
the equality of workplace deaths men do
most of the hard jobs plumbing
electricity all of the jobs where you
you can die on the job more men do it
and so they're they're the majority of
suicides they're the majority of
workplace deaths but no one cares
because they see men as expendable
all they care about is the one percent
jobs like do you want to be a fireman
like do women generally want to run into
burning buildings and help people no
but do they want to help people a
different way women will come become
midwives
but it's interesting because even in
this conversation like when we talk
about inequality it's always about the
women and no one cares about the man
yeah so what did jordan peterson say
over 90 percent of bricklayers are men
why are we not looking for equality in
bricklaying
oh my god there's too many men in
bricklaying girls you need to start we
need to start getting the female
quarters in women don't want to lay
bricks do you know what i mean
that's it it's that it's it's that
simple
but i also do feel it i also feel like i
think it's also based on what you're
exposed to as well so if you're not
exposed to a certain amount of jobs that
a lot of my friends have told you to
become a nurse to be a midwife that was
it from like from young and that's what
they thought to go into until they
exposed other things i think also
you're the way you're nurtured plays a
big part and i think
a lot of uh
girls and boys when young they're kind
of told what jobs you you should or
shouldn't do i think and i think that
kind of buys into it but i i think it's
more biological so i'm one of ten i have
ten siblings actually five boys and five
girls
and all the boys are engineers
i was never told what i could and
couldn't do i just was like engineering
that sounds terrible i think i want to
be an engineer girls typically pick pick
jobs with people
where men pick jobs with things and when
you pick jobs with things you get paid
more
to what you were saying about
you know the shortage of um camera
people and all the technical side it
relates more to the things rather than
people because
most guys well i'd say not all i can
speak for all most want to do the people
side of the media
mm-hmm
i mean even the people's side is still
not that
the best most women in in tv is plus
management because it's always
organizing
there's a that's
of presenters a lot of presenters are
women
the people that are actually in front
talking to people and things like that
those those a lot of them are women from
what i can see anyway
but there are like some sports that
aren't necessarily offered to women so i
can't remember who i was listening to
sports sports sports sports so like
for instance
i was listening to a female rugby player
um i don't remember her name right now
but she was mentioning that in school
she wasn't and she grew up in the uk she
wasn't offered the opportunity to play
rugby
and so she was just pushed into let's
say
more female sports like netball so she
didn't actually have the opportunities
yeah but you know what schools that tend
to be offered rugby tend to be more
private schools and grammar schools that
is true so
and and honestly like i'm uh i'm i'm i
play three sports in college and you
know i've looked at getting contracts
overseas and i think it's completely
fair that men get paid more at sports
and that they have more opportunity in
sports because as a business owner
you're trying to make money
and like who can name a wnba player
outside of brittany griner
i don't watch it what what the women's
world copies on at the moment right
is it getting the same coverage yeah as
as men's because
people gent don't care about football as
much as well but that's like from
childhood that's what i'm trying to say
it's not childhood i'm saying like we're
not as good and so even at schools if
there's more
if if there's more men's sports teams
it's probably because they could sell
more men's ticket to pay to pay for the
program because it's not free
like you have to pay the coaches you
have to pay the people the referees you
have to pay the people
to run the games
and so it's like if you're going to have
a program something has to pay for it
and i think isn't it free in the uk
though like well nothing's out of that
taxes i'm saying nothing i'm saying
nothing's free so even even if it comes
from like government money you still
have to decide what to do with it and
what has the biggest roi i don't think
the government should
um
basically allow everyone to have the
same opportunity so
so you know encourage women to play
rugby if they want to do women
you know what i think it's more i don't
think it's about okay so yeah a lot of
women don't want to do the nurturing
they'll say the bricklaying jobs and all
that high level labor will get hit
wherever but i think it's more of a case
of if someone does want to do that
can opportunity be there i think that's
the problem i think in times past it's
been a case of when women have want to
do certain things
it hasn't
when they have gone the door's been
knocked back do not mean so that's a
case of all women because not that women
are happy to just do what they're doing
live their life but a lot of i think a
lot of men get knocked back as well so i
don't think you can you can necessarily
say it's just women
it's the best person you have to go in
there with a with a mindset that i'm
gonna get this and you have to be
competent to make sure you can get it
like it men get knocked back all the
time when it comes to roles jobs and so
on and so forth because there's another
guy there that's just better
yeah if there was if there was enough
women actually asking to want to do it
i'm sure that they would like get little
girls how are they supposed to know
we've been in school but i'm saying like
why are we gonna push it on them
do you really think it's natural for
that women do you really think that
women playing rugby is natural
like just genuinely like just
come on do you think it's unnatural yes
yes
so you think there's something wrong
i don't think the question was do you
think it's natural like naturally women
want to do that or do they naturally not
that it's unnatural to do it no no i'm
saying do women naturally want to play
rugby do you think there's a long line
of women just dying to play rugby
where they get their yeah
they only get bad but if they're all
brought together from different parts
and like at least as an opportunity then
i'm saying if they're a minority yeah
you're right yeah and i'm saying like
why are we trying to push it on them
we're not pushing it we're just making
it available at the same level as it is
for men because that's what it was okay
so i'll give you a similar equivalent
i'll give you i'll give you a similar
equivalent at my college we had a
lacrosse team because it had to be equal
there's like title nine in the us
and they would bag girls to play
lacrosse like that like they were
recruiting me so hard i did like two
practices i was like nah skiing and so
it's like why are they pushing that on
it if girls don't want to do it
it's like you're putting like their
agenda on on women instead of what women
want to do naturally
right so what happens if there's the
minority that do want to do it
is there opportunities for them to do it
i'm not saying they should be paid the
same because i do agree it's a business
it needs to make money
but i'm just saying at least at school
let them be trained because this woman
had she missed 18 years of her life you
know she only had the opportunity when
she was 19 which delayed her a lot she
could have been a lot better at her
sport if there was at least an
opportunity i mean i think if there's a
large group of women that want to do it
sure but for one girl
like come on pick a different sport like
i'm sorry
like i'm an athlete right okay and there
were sports that weren't offered at my
school and i just picked a different one
i didn't go on tv and cry about it like
like boo freaking who we live would you
mean we don't have a synchronization we
live in the west we live in the we live
in the richest society in all of human
history like our lives are so good and
you're gonna [ __ ] because you weren't
offered freaking rugby
if there weren't people that did that
like we would still be let's say like
some countries in the middle east like
obviously there's some women that had to
say oh hang on i want to drive and then
things change so i want to return that
i'm like done driving
women are better drivers though you have
to admit no not
they're not they they have less
accidents but it's only because men
drive more
so actually like per yeah and men
actually drive more dangerously yes i
will say
yeah are better but the thing is but the
thing is women take less risks driving
so they're better no but it depends on
what you mean as better because no i
think they disprove you know
i think they disproved that really where
they like like that's what i thought it
was too but i want to say they just
disproved it and they said that actually
men are better drivers
men have less accidents for how much
they drive right okay so then when you
were saying women are better drivers why
is it there on this is not a formula one
women's
race because like why is there nothing
women's thing
that's a different type of driving which
no because
no no no no no that's not different day
to day i'm saying
for me to get from a to b
i'm the better driver
because i'm i actually who gave you this
title as yourself and insurance company
the insurance company insurance
companies before this is why i don't
know but it's because women drive it's
because women drive less that's why so
if you do something less there's going
to be less accidents mm-hmm so as i say
where i don't like feminists is they
complain about things that actually
benefit are you just disregarding the
fact that she just told you that what
right
she just disproved what you just said
and you would completely stick it with
yours
where did you get that from okay wait
wait wait how did she disprove what i
just because she explained that women
are having less accidents because
they're driving less
yeah so that that's what
you don't know when you when you compare
it
it just means that you drive less and
you have less accidents meaning that
you're a better driver so why do
insurance companies because they drive
less charge they drive less and they're
good
to do a risk when it comes to insurance
if you have a lower risk if you're like
a taxi driver is going to have a higher
a higher premium than a regular person
because you're on the road more more
okay like truck drivers truck drivers
are mostly men yeah their premiums for
their um insurance must be really high
because
just out of share numbers you're on the
road all the time you're more likely to
have an accident yeah it's like i've got
classic car insurance and they will give
you a low insurance because they limit
the amount of mileage so they say oh you
can only drive that car a certain amount
of miles and that's why it's lower well
it makes sense
every time i see someone like cut me off
or do something crazy it's always a girl
it's never a dude it's always like a
girl on her phone like
and like doing something wild swerving
in the intersection
i still don't see how that would like
benefit insurers if genuinely women were
worse drivers even if they were less
okay so women have more accidents for
how much they drive so it benefits that
or less accidents because they drive
less right so it benefits them because
if i'm just going to take a man and a
woman at large right the the woman is
less likely to have an accident i still
got her money so if you drive like
melbourne you don't have to pay out the
insurance companies don't have to pay
out your money
yeah so they'll be paying out more risk
one at a time companies only deal with
risk that's nice
so there's more risk the more you drive
yeah okay
now can i ask a quick a random question
um
it's on topic but do men as men do you
feel like
men should only speak amongst men when
it comes to
um like matters of
importance let's say do you feel like do
you feel like when men speak in public
what they're said what they're what
they're saying is taken as seriously as
women
talking about emotionally emotional
stuff oh and seriously
you you you keep that you keep that
to yourself and you're close
close circle yeah because um
girls don't want to hear that [ __ ]
they don't want to hear that they don't
want to hear
about you know whether your your fears
your insecurities whatever you're going
through you you work on that [ __ ] and
yourself you present
the company front
and that's you know that's what you got
to do
it's just
it's just the way it goes
and then you know you have to be there
for your boys when they're going through
it i mean i had to go through with a
friend of mine
you know he had to go to family court
and you know emotionally you know go
through all these emotions about his
daughter and everything else
and you know
as a mature man you got to be there for
your boys and go you know when they want
to talk even when they're crying and
still hold that respect but
you know i could see when he was having
those interactions with his significant
other it was causing friction
and you can't say to him hey man
we can but in a gentle way look
if there's any [ __ ] come to me
we could talk it through
without judgment
but you got to present because he's his
girlfriend his partner wants him to be
that strong leader
and she can't she
because she doesn't know what it takes
to be a leader in a male sense
the concept of him showing any kind of
weakness is like completely alien right
whereas
i know okay cool you're going to have
those quiet moments to yourself
where you know you're going to
you know you have to deal with whatever
you're going to deal with because life
love can be harsh
you know what's interesting that i
noticed so if a guy hits a girl what's
the immediate reaction
he shouldn't have done that
now what's the immediate reaction if a
girl hits a guy she shouldn't have done
that what did he do what did he do
that's exactly what people say or or
basic mind yeah definitely society was
that what what did he do yeah or even um
cheating songs like
next time maybe he'll think before he
cheats you know like and then she's
literally
vandalism
but if a guy does that to a girl he's
seen this crazy
insane but if a girl
is out your car yeah that's that's
that's
that's what jasmine sullivan said yeah
she also evolved they've listened to her
journey to her music now
she flipped that yeah but you don't but
you don't give that benefit of the doubt
to him like chris brown
oh my god he's toxic like chris brown
right like chris like chris brown nobody
says oh he's evolved that people still
complain that he performs and stuff even
though rihanna hit him first i mean yeah
and she i didn't know this yes she hit
him first with that whole i mean that
whole concept the people that want to
hold on to that to the past of that
that's really their business because
if you even watch his documentary about
the whole thing you see he's evolved if
you see how he's progressed but a lot of
a lot of women like to harbor one to the
past and not move on and that's
definitely an issue that we have as
women and that's what you see on social
media when people want to redeem
themselves and want to come back and be
different well that's why the johnny
depp case was so prominent wasn't it
because it showed women in a different
light yeah i mean by initially when she
came out and said he was an abuser
everyone believed her but that was
stupid yeah but the thing is it's like
that's that
whole thing with men of you know do we
get taken seriously it's like no women
do
well there's believe all women yeah
that's the most sexist thing i've ever
heard in my life believe all women why
the hell would i believe you just
because you're a woman you could be just
as crazy as the man can be yeah
i think you should believe women like
when it's like personal so let's say if
a woman i know or a woman i work with
came to me and told me like this
happened which has happened in the past
to me
and
automatically i think at that point you
should take that person seriously and
believe them however because i work in
league or i know that you know it's
innocent until proven guilty but i think
if someone privately in my private life
told me
especially if it's a woman because women
are more vulnerable we just can't just
sweep make sweeping statements like they
aren't i don't know i don't know like
sometimes i don't believe the girls that
tell me things because i think they're
full [ __ ] yeah women lie a lot like yeah
that's not let's not oh hello let's not
um forget that you know like i've grown
up with my friends and they're saying
what they've done with certain guys what
they haven't done and then you find out
it's true it's false and i think even
women come coming to tell you a story
about some whether it be
um you know essay or grape or what have
you there has to be a level discernment
and maturity to to to not charge in and
just believe and go straight ahead with
the woman but actually
fill out the facts and helping her
navigate that because my straight thing
on those kind of instances we're going
to the police we're going to talk about
that i think when they say like believe
they just kind of mean don't dismiss her
so it's not like believe and then like
okay what do they mean they mean no okay
those are the crazy
no regardless
that that means it's true that that is
what most of them
say another way you call it don't dis um
don't dismiss all women
yeah i think that should be the slogan
rather than
there's something behind the whole
phrase of a woman scorned you know a
woman scorned
he's just you know
he's lethal
what's the one thing women can do that
men can't do
is to weaponize their tears
do you know what i mean if a guy cries
his tears aren't weapons but if a woman
cries she knows her tears are weapons
she can have people believe her if she
cries guys don't get afforded that same
thing are you sure about that yes yes so
when a guy cries you know he gets made
into a meme where michael jordan cries
he was made into a meme and will smith
was crying he was made into a meme when
all of these guys are crying they get
made into memes
it's not the women making not even that
i'm just thinking but why are you why
are you offering an excuse
how is that anything because how do you
even know that how do you know who's
making the memes
because mean culture typically
is pushed by men i was speculating
about okay we all have to pick women
women women are the majority on social
media much more than men and so it's
like it's like there's always whenever
and this is just something i've noticed
in society whenever we say a problem
that men have it's always followed up by
but they do it to themselves right or
but
men do that too like it's never just
this is a problem well that's why we're
having the show because it's like yeah
men's stuff isn't taken seriously
because like i said like i said the the
way women can weaponize their tears is
not the same men can weaponize their
teeth
if a woman ran out right now off here
crying yeah you're more likely to get
garner attention than if a man ran out
of the hair right now crap i heard this
i heard this you know what i'm saying i
i heard this and i can't remember where
i where it is
i disagree so yeah i i heard this one at
a time
so i heard this and i can't remember
where i heard it but um but they said
that where the only time a a a woman is
really um
when a woman's tears are genuine it's
when she's by herself if she's if she's
if she's with anybody else normally the
tears aren't genuine
that's why that's what i heard i had to
think about that when i heard it i heard
that too
these are just like they brought is that
you can't remember where where where i
heard it by the way it makes total sense
because then there's no manipulation
they're not trying to manipulate anybody
around because they're on their own
if you're crying on your own
yeah i'm a woman yeah and i cry with
people okay let me explain it
if you're growing on your own that means
that there's no one else around you're
trying to manipulate with those tears it
means it's genuine because if
potentially there's another person in
the room
that you could be trying to carry some
sort of sympathy
or mercy or favor because you're crying
and women know they can get that don't
play that you can't fight
because even little kids do it look i i
i'm maybe i might talk for myself
apparently it's in this in this in this
no i didn't compare you to kids
conversation because
i have been in situations personally
where i have been crying
and
no one helped me i've called the police
and no one's helped me
i think white women's tears definitely
100 they've got that doubt that you know
as a black female who's big heavy and
tall i don't get that treatment do you
think your tears will be seen over a
black man's
um
by a society yeah yeah
because you still got the female you
still got the woman
i mean
do you know what i think
i actually think it'd be equal you know
maybe maybe maybe
okay i'm just i'm just curious i'm just
curious we're just gonna do a quick poll
because there are
four black men in this room
and your experience are your tears seen
as equal to black women go ahead
just pull quick absolutely not now go
ahead
no i don't know no
but should they
no no
emotion is emotion yeah right if
someone's hurt someone's hurt doesn't
matter if you're male female black white
whatever if you if you're if you're
showing emotion then that means you're
you're obviously hurt by something
you're not hurt by something
yeah but men don't get to weaponize it
but do you want to
it's not in our nature to weaponize our
emotions women
women women weaponize their emotions
they can weaponize
they can they do it everywhere
can i can i just you do every moment by
saying you know i
women are women are able to give an
excuse for every single poor behavior
that we do ever oh no
it's even
it's my star sign it's my yeah
yeah it's like yeah women get excuses um
i don't yeah women deaf excuses there's
loads i mean you could be a [ __ ]
because you're you know you're a gemini
sorry for sword there wouldn't like to
say that
um and on your point of when men don't
weaponize their tears maybe like on a
they can't well hold on maybe you're on
a sister
on a facial
on a face front they don't but when it
comes to
relationships and being toxic and all
those kind of things i've always heard
the story it hit me then he cried and
then i went back to because i felt bad
because i didn't do that there's so many
so i think maybe not in the public face
men don't have that so so that's oh
here's
me so many times that you hurt so for me
so like you said so if i'm in a
situation with a man for example and it
was to craft i would really question
that because of what i've heard that's
my experiences of what i've seen
so every time
every time we heard that story let's say
it was like what five times maybe
plus plus so ten times maybe you've
heard that story so every time you heard
the story they they hit the woman and
then cried mm-hmm or she tries to leave
then they cry so what people do you hang
around
like that's right like that's yeah
and second second second second thing
second second thing is that in the
majority of one-sided most abusive
relationships they're abusing each other
and the majority of one-sided abusive
relationships the woman is hitting the
man and he's not retaliating so women
are more abusive than men
why why does it matter it's wrong it
matters so that we can okay
if we want to say why i would say it's
because women get bailed out of
everything including abusing men they're
not held to the same like a guy is
afraid to hit a girl a girl's not afraid
to hit a man because look at what
happened amber heard if that happened to
a girl or a man with money status and
power what what does that mean for the
average guy
so like women just aren't held
accountable in society and men are seen
as expendable
which is probably why the suicide rate
amongst many so hide is um if you go to
anywhere in the western world
three quarters
of the suicides in anywhere is normally
male are those rich men or poor men
in general men in general but i do i do
think one thing i was thinking about
when you said about
um do the society care about what men
have to say and what men have to do and
i started thinking about
is it because men don't care enough that
society doesn't care as well so you know
how women have been screaming and
shouting for riots for this and that
they've been like a non-stop record for
their rights for their for whatever they
want to the point then we've had to
we've we've had to listen to them do you
think the campaigns for you know men
screaming and shouting about we're not
heard we're not going it's enough for
you it's happening it's ridiculed
because you remember when they used to
have um
the men who wanted their fathers who
wanted to see their kids and their
injustice exactly fathers of justice
be kind of written off and ridiculed
they're out there they've been saying
things but
the slant for society and the media just
doesn't give them a voice well even
there was a feminist a couple years ago
that did a documentary on men's rights
and the whole documentary
was aimed like she didn't she didn't
like it going into it she like was like
what what what rights do men need and
she went into it changed her opinion and
had a completely different opinion at
the end she was like you know what men
are actually seen as lesser in society
and are discriminated against that was
her conclusion and people protested the
movie wow and even men's rights like we
always hear about women's rights we
never hear about men's rights
and even like the red pill space it's
labeled as misogynistic and they hate
when i'm told i hate women every day
because i advocate for men
and even whenever i bring up a men's
issue it's always followed with a butt
and it's it's always a but either like
men have this problem too like men do it
too or it's a butt like what about us
yeah so remember
men only really started speaking in this
space
for about five years really intriguing
burst into the scene like the manosphere
and the red pill community of kind of
obviously with kevin samuels it bursts
into the scene but even prior to that
and men having an opinion
seems to rub people the wrong way but
don't
women have had talk shows for decades
they've had magazines you've had spaces
where you can express yourself i think
those men
i think those opinions were were there
like there were sectors of of of men and
had those opinions but they weren't we
didn't have youtube where it was easy
access to the mics and the computers and
you can put stuff out there straight
away so look at that there was people
like i remember listening to
uh patrice o'neill like in like 2000
men had to do it through comedy do you
know i mean yeah 2009 i remember this he
was serious and and it was and he was
bringing up some of this some of the
same sort of sort of topics that people
talk about right yeah but you've done it
in a comment in comedic so when kevin
samuels didn't do it comedic yeah you
saw the fury it was another comedy or it
was an informal chat amongst men well
it's like i i say this all the time if
if we had a song called i don't want no
whales i don't want no fatties
but i'm
yeah
that was in response to no scrubs
and it's not but it's it's okay for
every one example you can name we can
always name five ten i can name i can go
through cardi b songs megan estellian
songs city girls why men great
dance
but those songs
aren't really good for women
those songs are not really good for
women either which ones
cardi b and all the if a woman lived her
life like that
oh i i agree i don't think i don't think
it's good advice
but at the end of the day it still
benefits women because it's saying you
can be as promiscuous as you want how
does that stop women
the message is that you can be as
promiscuous as you want and still get a
husband at the end of it
and that's a message that benefits women
you can not cook you cannot clean and
you could still get male attention and
get a husband that's not even how these
girls live their lives like cardi b you
think she's not cooking and cleaning of
course
but
like it's not a good message to send to
women but like the point is the music is
still talking about something that
benefits women
i just think when it comes to music it's
just purely entertainment so a lot of
things are said more just for shock
factor more just because it's not
entertaining when your daughter's
twerking on the floor or when your son's
trying to trap so yeah yeah it's not
entertaining when your door was twerking
on the floor sorry
but that's the responsibility of parents
as parents for both the father and the
mother
for exposing their children how could
they how can you avoid it like the
average age of a kid seeing corn what
was it 11 12.
it's like with the internet well it's
not avoiding but it's teaching your
children at a young age good morals
and so like when i have kids i'm not
going to just blindfold them throughout
the world but you train them and you
prepare them i just think that's a lot
easier said than done and it's really
hard to
like shield your kids from the culture
music has to be relatable in order for
it to resonate with the people that are
listening to it so
it comes from a real place most of the
time yeah it's not just entertainment if
if you can make a song called what where
else [ __ ] yeah then there's a lot of
women out there
thinking and talking about their whap
yeah but for it to bang
who's coming to the house the women go
to a cardi b concert and the mega
standard concert and see if what the
majority of
men are i took i was watching
songwriting classes um off of youtube
and the guy said something um
about writing songs and one of his
advice is like the women that's your
audience so make sure the woman's the
victim in the song
oh good ballad come on yeah dude that's
what i'm saying it's always it's always
the woman well yeah because sometimes it
won't sound i mean based on how we use
it
based on how we see society wouldn't
benefit a man saying to the left to the
left get out of my house wouldn't it no
but put it on like a female listen like
neo said and you've got a banger and in
the day where they're going to be the
ones in the club singing our heart out
heartbroken or not cause it's a song the
rich blitz have you have you not heard
the new dsvn tune yeah i heard that
right
if i get caught cheating that doesn't
mean i don't love you
i'm sure you're not going to let one
little [ __ ]
mess all this up
and women are losing their minds on
twitter about this song right
people are saying listen women have been
making songs like this about men taxes
these guys doing this i mean that's the
reality though i think many women are
angry because being exposed for what we
take back but let's face it what he's
singing is what what men have been
saying to their woman for years and
years it's just reality what he's
singing is just reality it's just the
reality of what's going on this is
society at the end of the day yeah he we
just weren't able to say stuff like that
out in the open and it be actually
received do you know what i mean the
same way i just said that but it's being
called misogynist the backlash yeah
people instantly call it misogyny
misogynistic how is that how is that
misogyny is
did you say it is i said it oh you said
it why do you use that misogynistic
if i get caught cheating that doesn't
mean i don't don't love you how is that
because it is just the definition of not
loving someone how can you cheat on
women have different definitions of how
they love each other no no no no love is
no you're sacrificing for you but yeah
that's what you're you're looking at it
you're looking you're looking at it
you're looking at it from a female's
point of view no i'm looking at it from
who who so do men want to be cheated on
them it's not that they want to be it's
that cheating's different for men and
for women because historically men
wanted to screw as many people as
possible where women had to find the
highest quality mate
and so we can't get undo our biology
just because society is different
today they have pretty much and so like
i've heard guys say they would have sex
with a hole in the wall that's what
you're saying right yeah guys have sex
who's on that a girl where a girl they
have to have something
it's a corn category isn't it yeah yeah
like like girls they have to have
something and it's like that's why men
are the major corn consumers yeah but do
if if you're saying is different right
and men are the ones to do like men are
to love women right because if if you're
in a heterosexual relationship
and so women will receive are the
recipients of the love and so the way
that the man is loving the woman the
woman is telling you i am not feeling
that as love so it's like if i'm selling
something i'm going to cater it to the
person who's the consumer so let's say
with the man and the woman the woman is
consuming that love and so you telling
me that the way i i love you i need you
though okay
okay so there's a man loving a woman
okay right the way a woman receives love
you said love for a man and love for a
woman is different right because like a
man it's his his way of showing love is
resources time and attention where woman
is loyalty like we love in different
ways his way of showing it
doesn't mean it's going to be received
and if there's no point me like if i had
a business there's no point me showing
things that are not going to be received
well you can you can pick who you date
but often times girls pick the guy they
know cheats and then cry when he cheats
they have daddy issues i don't think
they have daddy issues they just want
they just want a very small percentage
of men
i mean even even so
sorry do you think that a manchin
instantly means that he doesn't love his
woman is that what you're saying
so if a man cheats with a woman he does
he no longer loves his woman
i would say he might love her but i
would say he's not he's not acting in
love he's not acting so what you're
saying is a man cheating on a woman
doesn't exactly equate to him not loving
her
at that very moment he's not acting in
love so i it depends on what you see
lovers
i see love is more as an action yeah so
so what if a girl
what if a girl isn't giving her husband
sex does she not love him
is she not acting and i think if a woman
is deliberately not giving him no it's
not deliberately she just she just
doesn't know she doesn't feel like it
because remember because that's that's
how that's how that's how that's how men
receive love right mine will be no no
guys no guys nobody is going to marry a
girl if you don't wait do men receive
love through sex i thought it was women
that give um sex for love no they're
they're more bonded through sex but no
man's going to marry a girl unless she's
getting sex out of it you tell you you
say you want to talk
no they're like okay
they're like next okay so back to the
question so i'm saying if she's not
sleeping with him would you would you
make it equal
so like she's not loving him because
that's how men feel loved
i mean it
i would say i have to i have to say it
does depend because if she's if she is
ill or something but i think in oh yeah
okay so 20 20 20 20 to 25 of marriages
are sexless meaning they've had less
than sex less than once a month in the
past year yeah i think that is so so so
that's one out of four that's a pretty
big percentage so so that would mean
that would mean that but would you which
women don't love wait would would the
women would the men still be happy for
the women just to put up and have sex
like dead sex just yeah
yeah okay
is it the same yes or no it is it is the
same so you you would say it's equal
then so then a woman doesn't love a man
if she's not giving him sex
yes
yeah okay
[Music]
if a woman doesn't give a guy sex for
like
okay i'm because i'm a christian i'm
gonna say maybe in the context of
marriage because yeah like for me that's
like the the context that i i wouldn't
say i don't love um let's say my partner
because
i'm not having sex with him right now
because i would say
for me it's in the context of marriage
this is a word salad right now would you
understand i don't know if that would
this is a word salad because when i
asked you i said if a man cheats on a
woman does that automatically mean that
he doesn't love her
your man you're you're engaged your man
cheats on you
i'm not putting this on you by the way
but if that happened does that mean he
no longer loves you
like i said i would say no but i would
say at that point he's not acting in
line right so the point that we're
trying to make is that
men can just like going back to the song
if i get caught cheating that doesn't
mean i don't love you yeah yeah yeah it
goes because which is male nature
so he's talking about his nature as a
male he can have sex with someone and
still love his woman but then men can do
that it goes back to talk about it it
goes back to the point of the story
because man why is that misogyny you
said it was you used that word
because how can it be how can just him
tell him
about male nature
what's misogynistic you said that song
was misogynistic yeah yeah sorry what's
how would you define misogynistic well
you said it you said it so so you're
you're moving it again yeah you said it
no no i just want to make sure we're
both talking about the same thing so i
know what i mean when i say what do you
what do you mean i i i personally mean
it's against women okay and i just
wanted to make sure that's what you guys
mean how is that against women
can i just before you answer that yeah
the definition of misogyny is the hatred
of women
which is very dear so not the against
not being against women okay it's the
hatred of women so when people use the
word misogyny and they mean in different
contexts
as opposed to hatred yeah it's like
it's a loose i think i think one of the
major things which really
pee me off about the generation that we
live in today is that we just use
frivolous terms yeah without just
without knowing what we're talking about
we use it because it becomes a buzz word
and we use it because we know the
internet it can galvanize a certain
group of people behind you do you know
what i mean so when people use the term
misogynistic or when they use the term
patriarchal they know that those are
trigger words for certain groups of
people that will be like oh my god it's
misogynistic oh my god it's patriarchal
that means i don't like it and you can
galvanize now a group of people behind
you
we need to start thinking a little bit
more about where we think is that what's
a shame
use those words as a mic drop it's
almost like right i won yeah i said oh i
said yeah i said misogyny mic drop can i
ask the men a question though
yeah go for it so what if your let's say
your daughter
was
um going through that situation and her
man was telling her listen i love you
but i'm gonna cheat on you on a regular
i would say
if i have a daughter and if she's with a
man that wasn't honest with her from the
beginning then she made a mistake yeah
right because if a man is gonna be like
that he should have told you that from
before you got emotionally involved
right so if he's now telling you that i
would have i would i would say to my
daughter listen you got involved with a
man that you didn't know
okay and so it's now for you
it's now for you to make a decision i
can't make it for you as your father but
you got involved with him and he didn't
know are you willing to to be okay with
it but you're saying that it's love so
she shouldn't feel any way she should
feel oh my gosh she still loves me she's
presenting a choice he's presenting the
situation the reality of his situation
and she has to make a choice is this guy
who's saying look you're my main girl
and i'm going to give you all of these
things and that i'm
of certain value
is this worth
this is worth it this is cool for you
you're going to be the one the main girl
i look for you're the main girl i love
this might be something on the side
but it doesn't mean anything
is it gonna balance out is it worth it
but
if you asked your daughter does she feel
loved in that moment when her man is
cheating but it wasn't it's not the the
statement the state but the statement
you said was that he doesn't love her
and so that's he's not acting in love
that's what i am no according to you yes
okay and i think according to the
definition of love no what's the
definition no no we're not taking your
definition you can't tell a man how he
loves a man will tell you how he loves
you might then he can love a man
it doesn't make sense if the woman is
the one
i
i don't think you're making sense not at
all no no no i i know i'm making sense
so what i'm saying is it's the woman
receiving the love so you tailor it it's
like whatever audio
but you're but you're so you're going to
you're you're but you're as a woman
you're going up to men and saying love
how we love yes because we love through
loyalties
yes you're saying love how women love
but men and women are different and so
that's what that's what like the modern
woman does she goes up to men and says
be women yeah be women
and then when men are women you don't
like them no i think you guys don't
understand me i am also saying to the
woman as well as to love as
to love the man
as he feels loved there's no point in
loving a man
in a woman's correctness
what if that man said
um
i in order for me to feel loved i
wouldn't cheat no no no i would like i
would prefer to have sex at least four
times a week
yeah i think the woman
but she doesn't i think if she if she's
told up front i think she should be told
that from the beginning like listen i
have a high sex drive
but i mean the equivalent of that would
be a man going up to a girl and saying
provide yeah exactly that's the
equivalent that's like that's not the
same like
what you're asking of men and you're
saying that's not love because you're
saying if you cheat on me that's not
love that's like a guy saying if you
don't pay for the bills that's not love
yeah so you're saying because men and
women are different so you're saying the
purpose of men because women might see a
man's purpose in in his purpose is to be
a provider yeah because traditionally
historically
biological roots and historically you
needed
historically women picked men that she
did why do you think women have all
these songs about men being trashed
because we like the men that cheat
between
girls like guys who cheat because
they're like the guys who have the
capacity to cheat yes because it's
social proof they're like it's like you
know you're not going to go to a club
with no queue you know when you see the
big queue outside the club it makes you
wonder yeah eight thousand
and some women are social creatures like
that eight thousand eight thousand years
ago seventeen women reproduced for one
man
wow
so yeah so it's like you can't it's 17
years ago or sorry 8 000 years ago 17
women reproduced for one man so you're
you're going up to men and saying change
your biology change it
just and so that's that's like men going
up to women and saying provide for me
provide so you'd be happy if a man
cheats on you i'm not i'm not gonna be
happy but i just loved i'm not i'm not
gonna feel loved but i'm saying i'm not
gonna tell him that you not you don't
love me because you cheated but then is
that man had to make
sex to 17 women back in eight thousand
years he probably had sex with no no no
no no
but then was he but
what was was he cheating was out front
it's the whole the whole issue of
cheating is the lie everything that goes
with it we're not we're not
we're not advocating i'm not advocating
for cheating i don't have no issues but
i'm saying i'm not all i'm saying is
that men and women are different and
they love in different ways that's my
only point go ahead i know and i agree
with you i just feel like it's just
with the cheating thing mm-hmm it's just
like it's the like it's the lies and
it's the lies and stuff that
would affect the cheating because the i
mean because is it cheating if you all
know what's happening
i think part of the issue here
is
that
the whole cheating not cheating but
an
external relationship to relation to the
whole situation is being presented in a
logical way and i think if it's
presented
to go in an emotional way like there's
an emotional investment and it's like
look there's a bond there's a connection
this is the situation
a girl will gravitate towards that yeah
they're more likely to go with that than
going hey look me and you we're gonna
start going out and by the way there's
about three or four other girls i'm
going to hook up with
you know are you cool with that
on a logical sense you're going to say
no but in reality once there's a
connection there's a chance that they
may say well they might go along with it
and i'm not saying that okay that's the
way i've operated but
you can see it like with the tinder
swindler so many girls saying no no no i
never would have gone for that i never
would have gone for that and he's like
no
because because he presented yeah once
she wants to once they're baited once
they're baited in the situation i'm not
talking about as predatory in a way but
like because it could tend to cinder was
a tinder swindler was a conrad artist
and anyone in the con
needs to be baited they need to be
feeling their approach in their dream or
whatever
and people once their their logical
logical brain is cut off
they're more likely to think more
emotionally well and women i mean modern
women are side checks because i mean we
swipe on five to twenty percent of
tinder likes and the majority of people
meet online
so we're we're all picking the same guys
and then come and then crying that we
get cheated on it's like you picked up
but you know what i think is is
hilarious we started this whole thing
saying
oh does society accept men or are men
not loved i don't care about you care
about men
i don't know if no one cares about men
who are the men going out and cheating
it's a small percentage of men
most men can't you can't get anyone one
out of three men haven't had sex in the
past year and even if they get married
20 of them don't even get sex anyway the
average guy like i said the average guys
dms are dry yeah the average guy doesn't
get attention from women when women know
you as women know you can walk out of
your house
with a bonnet on and track suit bottoms
and still garner attention from men and
is there anything stop no hang on hang
on hang on i'm saying men don't get that
so
the reason why what we're saying is that
there's a small percentage of men that
are getting most of the women
and most of the women are going for
those men women the majority of men
women rate 80 of men as unattractive not
okay unattractive where men swipe right
50 percent of the time yeah that's
because
half the time they're looking for one
thing like
if you're coming if you're online and
you swipe a guy you could not think he
only saw your picture and swiped you
like of course he's been swiping swiping
men are that possibility the more you
swipe than what someone's going to pick
you women are definitely a lot more
picky in in that sense so
yeah i mean it's going to bound to
happen i don't think if you take men
online serious then boy but you're
you're moving the goal post because the
whole point is that like men and women
are different and men don't the average
guy doesn't get any attention from women
ever so what stops the average guy from
being a one percent guy oh they secure
because there's things that stop women
like women if you're not the right
face
if you're not the right shape or
obviously you can get in shape of all
shapes but if you don't look beautiful
if you're not like okay bbl you can get
you can get plastic surgery
on top on top of that you can be in the
top 20 of women if you're just in really
great shape because most women are
overweight
here and in the us
do men look at women for that their
their their shape or maybe like the face
i mean i mean it depends on the guy but
a lot of guys will take a girl with a
great body and an okay face like a lot
of guys 100 yeah men do but i think if
okay if that as long as men may be under
the mic sorry as long as men make money
what is the issue the issue is you make
money you can do what you want right so
if you just make the money you do what
you want and that's how hard it is for
you no but the thing is you're not
understanding that we live in a
generation now where
women are telling men
or are giving men unrealistic or giving
themselves and men unrealistic
expectations for the money that you're
talking about right so the average man
will earn 45k
right women are talking about oh they
want a man with six figures and he's
gotta be this and he's gotta be six foot
tall when you talk about men being six
foot two
it's only what less than fifteen percent
of men are six foot two right so you you
you're you're you're pricing yourself
out of the height you're pricing
yourself out of the money so these
average dudes which aren't six foot and
they don't make 100k they're the ones
that are walking around like what about
me but a woman would go with like what
about me average height man
if he earned enough for for the right
price so there's an issue i don't think
height is that okay so most of these
guys i kind of put it when girls are
looking online
they're looking in a very logical way so
they could work in with like a shopping
list right so it's only those guys who
uh
who are maybe under six for who don't
have that money who have the confidence
and the skill
to me to go in person who can overcome
that
and it's also
women are incentivized to catch a kid
or a bag from a dude
so like yeah he could have money but
like the majority of the women the
world's richest women are all from
divorce
i mean well if the average man is
earning 45k i
i think trapping an average man would
wouldn't be great would it because i
might say that again you said women are
incentivized they're rewarded for bad
behavior and you said something about
the richest women and on the planet or
the majority of them got their money
from divorce because because women are
incentivized to divorce men and get kids
off of their children
yeah they're rewarded which is why
divorce rate eighty percent of divorces
are initiated by women in the us it's 90
if you're college educated over here
it's 64 percent
of women that initiate divorces so it's
the women that are saying well you know
what i don't want any more and a lot of
the time they get a bag out of it they
get house they get cars they get the
children
it's good so it's it's it's it's but are
they happy and i think and i think if
men if if society really did care about
men then the the laws around
marriage would be very very more uh
50 50
women that make
why because women win elections
like that's it's interesting because a
lot of the election strategies are
similar to the marketing strategies that
they use and women make 70 to 80 of
consumer buying decisions so
men know that if they want to get
elected they can run on certain issues
and manipulate women emotionally like
for example like roe versus wade they
can just run on that and then women will
come cry into the polls
oh no let me kill my kid
yeah that went
very well
it's true
it's true it's like that's
that's like a woman's right now you know
like we talk we've spoken about grape in
on and off yeah in the show right yeah
and
did you guys know that one in 20 people
that are graped are mean
do you know that yeah i need one in five
minutes
yeah and obviously men are less likely
to
um
speak about it it's funny because i say
it's funny because even on here there
was a guy on here a few weeks ago who
said that he had like an essay situation
i'm not gonna lie i was listening to it
i was like
really and and i had to check myself
like wow like i'm really questioning
that and i'm a man so you're not
supposed to believe him
what i was supposed to at least like
hear him out but when i heard it i was
like ah but then i was like oh my god
you're doing that
you don't realize that if you look
because you're hurt
if you look at it from the same
standpoint that that women would would
consider essay then yeah it happens
daily when it comes to women to men like
it happens all the time you know i've
definitely had
women come up to me and just sort of go
grab you and go for the crap
because technically it is by the
standards that
women have set but i actually think
lesbians get away with that as well
well like ellen she got away with i
can't remember who she groped but she
did grope someone in the picture without
their consent um so and i think so
basically women are allowed to wait
wait did that did that did that did that
person press charges
no but they did look uncomfortable
but i'm saying if yeah okay it's like
then press charges i think like i just
don't i don't just believe people just
because they say things like anyone can
say something go press charges yeah and
also on your point of when um
so i've got your name so sorry sorry
you know
that's the problem the thing is we need
to call things out more and you know
because
one thing that does make me sad is the
fact that you know
men are higher um suicide rates and
investing all those kind of things
because you know and much as you're
saying no one cares what have you okay
is the psycho going to care about you
let some
therapy therapist or someone because in
the day you are you you are kidding
yourselves and
ultimately
like we do need men like you know much
as women i mean twitter is i mean social
media ultimately is a place where if you
indulge in it enough you would think all
men hate women or women hate men you
know racism at war over time and the
rest of the rest of it but if you take
that away and look at your life as a
person individual ultimately
you need a man in your life you want a
man in your life so i think and and we
need you guys so yes we saying pull up
and make your money no difficult but if
if you don't feel loved and you don't
feel care then you need to talk to
someone because ultimately i do need you
i agree how are you gonna how are we
gonna have kids i'm not even one for
kids but
ultimately we do and especially in the
black community we need you guys like we
can't lead ourselves and we know that
and i think that's half the frustration
i think when from black women about
you know of the frustration of us what
leaders and once when certain men you
know so we're not saying kill yourself
and no one cares like yes twitter and
touched me to make you feel that way but
i think in our communities and what have
you we do care and we do want you guys
to be there for us and with us
what do you think guys
i agree yeah
that that sounds
i think it's a lovely lovely message but
then you look at some of the dynamics
that
you see in relationships
and
some of the advice that girls are
getting from their friends
and it
it goes completely in contrast
not single a lot of people are donuts my
issue is that we're not reading enough
we're not actually educating ourselves
back in the day i don't have the social
media to go and ask them to go and ask a
question and then for me to make a
formal opinion on that question a lot of
girls will be like i will never do that
men say i will never do that my men have
told me they will never get of a girl
after cheating him i know people have
done that on undercover but they've done
it then my women say if a man cheated me
i'll leave him these things might
actually happen in real life that's true
it's only on social media we have an
opinion but the average that if you look
at the average family or the average
people around you i've got friends in
love with relationships i've got friends
in abusive relationships it's all very
different but if i go on the social
media
and look at when they pick one thing i'm
gonna only get one thing and i and i've
realized that myself that i was on a
path of hating men that know all men of
trash was a really fun statement to say
you know and go around all my trash but
ultimately i have i have i have for
people in my life men that are not trash
i had to ask yourself where did those
opinions come from from a lot of these
young girls i don't they haven't got
sense
and if you and if you if you haven't got
said if you haven't got a sense you
haven't got a sense you shouldn't be a
man in the purpose anyway do you think
that message comes from um the media and
music what the
women are trash
um i would say it's definitely a bit of
breath i mean for music for me i don't
necessarily
for me it's at the time it's a story
because same way this is like you
fastest gangster happens of a certain
things about killing people what have
you you know i don't take that on so
therefore i'm gonna take on you know the
weapon whatever else they're saying i
just you know if i won if i wanted for
that like i'm a stripper i put some
cardiff b
well it's because everything's catered
towards women and women are bailed out
of every bad decision that we make
do you think yeah i mean okay okay think
about it okay if a woman sleeps around
right yeah well she's bailed out with
birth control if that fails would she
bailed out with an abortion if that
fails would she build out with child
support if that fails which or if she
gets married and that fails what's she
bailed out with alimony or child support
again
it's like if a woman is bad with her
finances and she's homeless what does
she have a woman's shelter there's not
men's shelters not like that
there's not like they're men's rights
issues it's always women's rights issues
if a woman is unhappy about something
there's marches if a woman doesn't like
men's standards there's fat shaming
slut-shaming like it whatever we do and
there's a potential consequence like we
are bailed out or who's supporting
like
women is it just women supporting or is
it because the world is made of men and
women i would say i would say it's beta
ass dudes that like they're trying to
get laid so they they push the [ __ ]
forward even though they know it's
nonsense and women because the emotion
is the order or or money like rolo
tomasi shout out um says if you want to
make a million dollars like convince
give
sell women the fear of missing out and
something that makes them look younger
i mean that's just some [ __ ] which is an
emotional it's an emotional thing i said
you spoke earlier women deal with their
emotions more so than their logic but
i'm going to read super chat
i'm going to read super chats real quick
so
um guys we are going to turn on members
only mode for the second half of the
stream so if you want to be a part of
the chat um we're turning on members
only mode now
on top of that guys we are trying to get
issue camera i think it's coming in soon
it's coming in it's it's hopefully
saturday yeah hopefully saturday's show
we can get issue camera what is the next
thing we should save for um
next thing we should what should we what
should we buy next
for a couple ideas couple ideas we can
we could talk about it later okay we'll
talk we'll talk
um but let me know in the chat what we
should get next also guys there is 2 300
of you in here and there's not a
thousand likes the audacity like this
goddamn video come on
like the video let's get to a thousand
likes in here also guys
like our facebook page like our twitch
page and follow my instagram it's just
early things so we also got twitter as
well oh yeah and i'm on twitter oh my
gosh i have too many things to plug i
forget it's pearly things with the z i'm
trying to get to 10k followers on
twitter i'm trying to be like cool so
okay brit cormier
make more money how hard can it be
there's only so many jobs that pay 100k
some of those are held by women women
want men who does not cheat only date
short ugly men how hard can it be
that's funny um gennaro rita's 74. math
stops an average guy from being a one
percent guy ff what does ffs stand for
should i know this for [ __ ] sake
i'm being educated
perfect
is that disney that's great does the f
word get flagged on youtube i'm gonna
say for f's sake okay math doesn't allow
everyone to be in the top percent shea
and pro men can be honest and have to
lie men who can't be honest and have to
lie to women are not men men who can't
be honest and have to lie to women are
not men so it's okay for a man to expose
his woman to stds and hiv
lauric bullock if you want a 100
faithful man find a man that no other
woman wants
brit cormier patrice o'neill has the
perfect
analogy so you got to smell
you got to smell fish on me so you can
know i can catch fish so you can act
right
i like that one look at it it's a toxic
bath the
rest in peace
um okay um
sorella bass the definition of love is
an intense feeling of deep affection
diversity fields these talking points
are easy to debate if a man loved his
woman he wouldn't go seeking out other
women for pleasure happiness etc clearly
he doesn't love his woman if he's
cheating dub men nine eight nine seven
perfect ten for the woman in the black
um way to stick to way to stick the
dismount in the metal oh way to stick
the dismount in the mental gymnastics
basics of plane over the last 60 years
men's spaces have been destroyed as
misogyny or invaded by women meanwhile
women are allowed in allowed spaces
excluding men what is left over for
women four to eight times more likely to
check out is what
nightingale 21. all right cool get that
man his camera let's go
get that man his camera sir the uk
economist pearl's looking very elegant
today thank you i try
um
the uk economist can you oh i will ask
the guest that question but i'm gonna
ask it at the end nightingale are we
still going for that camera i think it's
coming in soon so i think we're we're
gonna find a new thing to you know
raise money for
johnny barthel just showing the support
for the show
young ill thomas if you're going to ask
why do women hit men do you ask why men
hit women i'm sure the answers are the
same
dj befit a man who weaponizes his
emotions is going to prison
um tommy m will smith michael jordan
tyrese all turned into memes smh
um alex aleister horton i often sat the
term sympathetic doesn't contain the
word simp and pathetic by coincidence
you know
um we're in
warren can you ask the panel should they
get rid of the wnba thank you for
addressing the double standards between
me and women by opening the dialogue um
edardo hillbrand considering that she is
concerned about the men dominating the
camera market you could not
you could sign with her if she wants if
not why not
das token e30 where i live in the u.s
there is a free home builders course
that you can take here in the south
they're hurting for builders no women
are there the savvy ninja sports people
like physical display none outside of
gymnastics and a couple other sports
provide the most value in the display of
talent
demetrius farn is there a way to ban i
feel and only say what you know
killmonger not shaming women i'm in the
u.s military but they have a strong they
have made working for and with difficult
between the power trips or victim
olympics they may they make work harder
especially in combat not hate just
speaking from experience
the savvy ninja when it comes to the
word
provide money isn't the end-all be-all
are not the top five billionaires
divorced women as they gave welfare to
black women to degrade the black man
need i say more
ask your
panel if they can name one plus size
male model
um
alistar horton it's mostly down to men
thinking more with their head than
between their legs and um
thinking with
more with the head between their legs
and the head on their shoulders
j man pearl is it harassment day
harassment day harassment day was last
week but we will have in the name of
equality harassment day next week so
okay so i'm going to get harassed next
week well
okay yeah in the name of equality the
name request yeah i'll bring my best
pickup lines okay cool
um national holiday aleister horton
welcome back pearl how was the trip trip
was good thank you
um
and then there's a couple questions okay
pearl
ask the panels excuse me question if the
error in the world was filled with a
truth telling gasps for 72 hours who
would be in more trouble men or women
women
that's a good question i would say women
go
what did you say oh
i'm not gonna lie that is that is very
difficult i would say
both are in trouble
both are in trouble do you know
i don't think
that i don't think men will be in
trouble yeah women i think when i think
women i think women can know intuitively
already like their man isn't moving
right so it's not going to come as a
huge surprise whereas men are less
observant
doesn't exist for me exists for women
do you know what i mean like women are
under that oh my god um yeah i guess
you're not the dad do you know what i
mean so i'm just saying if it was true
serum i think a lot of men would find
out that their children are not theirs
so who's in trouble there women women
definitely
i think women i have it also because men
don't see women in a certain light for
certain things so certain women you just
don't think they do certain stuff and
then a true sermon comes out like wow
and you're going to feel better that's
because women are multi-dimensional and
i don't mean that in a bad way when
women have different sides to them
and
over time of age
we've seen that you know a lot of girls
reinvent themselves over time you know
that girl who was hardcore party girl
born again virgins yeah
they become spiritual they become
spiritual into healing and all that
stuff and they kind of leave oh my gosh
at once once i saw
the rolo's book when he talks about how
girls find god around like 26 to 30
right right when like time's running out
to find a husband i like could not unsee
it i was like ruined church for me
forever even with the church thing i
think the most geekiest guys ugliest
guys get the hottest girls in church
because they show how spiritual they are
so i think the same way women are
running out of age because they're kind
of a man i'm just like you know you're
going because of god
but here's why
here's the thing it's a mating strategy
it's basically like like what i've seen
is it's typically girls that have been
like ran through so they're trying to
they're trying to up their values so
they're saying okay i'm spiritual now i
found god whatever so they're they're
basically saying okay you have to pay a
higher price even though the value even
even the value this happens all the time
this is like chess like i did i did
catholic school 12 years we had a
chastity speaker come in and she
re-waited till she was married even
though she slept with all these guys in
high school and they're marketing this
like this is this is a bad deal for men
are you saying that yeah
and so so it's a mating strategy so the
man it's like it fulfills his mating
strategy because he he's usually like a
less like more of a beta like kind of a
simp because there's so many simpson
churches and so
like it fulfills his mating strategy
because he usually gets a girl that's
kind of out of his league but she's like
ran through so it's like
so it's like she might be attractive but
she's got like maybe a couple of kids
and yeah like she's been run through the
guys kind of because i've actually heard
church women say that the men in church
are either all taken
or they're all the types of guys that
they don't really want to be with and
then generally what tends to happen is
women in the church because the church
is majority women as we already know
yeah um the women want to find a man
they do find a man they find him outside
of the church and they bring him in and
they bring him in and then the pastor
says you're not equally yolked and you
can't be with that guy yeah but she's
dumb because obviously you know at the
beginning what equally yoke means so you
should be going for someone yeah but the
thing is women
but women want a partner they're not
attracted to those people and most of
them are interested
because clearly he's not going to work
so why are you going to go for someone
you can't because there's not there's
not enough men in the churches like and
it's usually three three women for one
dude
but i'm saying if if it comes down to
the point of you know eagle yolks and
what have you
that woman really there's no point for
something it's not gonna work in it
unfortunately i think it can work i
think the church as i've said before i
think the church keeps women single
i think the church keeps women
perpetually you're right about that
right yeah i think that you know from
the pastor to the teachings to the way
in which they're expected to deal with
men i think it keeps women and they and
they take all they take all
accountability off of women churches do
it too and it's even i remember in high
school listening to this chastity
speaker because she comes in and like
it's always oh i was so broken blah blah
blah like shut up you were horny like
why are you like shut up
and so she'll come in and say i was so
broken i made all these decisions i just
felt so bad about myself not
really i mean kind of taking
accountability but not not really you
know
and
then um all i had to do was say sorry
and i had a husband waiting for me at
the end and that's just not it's almost
like it was like a christian another
twist on the cardi b record i can be a
whole how where where is purity culture
in
it's in christianity yeah yeah but
there's a difference between like the
bible and like
christian culture so that just that's
just something that is invented for
today like it hasn't always existed
right
like the whole purity culture that like
the bible teaches to be pure
like for god not so you can get a man or
so you can get on women but in today's
society obviously some churches want to
attract more attendants and so they
promise these women who have been run
through as you say
that oh if you just keep yourself pure
you're going to get a man but that's
nowhere found in the scriptures
so that's just a message that's tailored
to the modern women today yeah but i'm
saying it's found in churches like so
you're trying to yeah you're trying to
take it off at churches but churches are
the one doing it no i'm not talking
about that church is i'm taking it off
the bible like christianity because i'm
not i'm not hating i'm not hating on
christianity like yeah i'm just i'm just
saying like i grew up i grew up catholic
like right i go to christian church
right but
i'm just saying it's a problem do you
think it's a good strategy though
like for a woman to have been run
through to go to church quote unquote
run through to go to church to find a
new man what do you mean what do you
think is a good do you think is a good
mating strategy for women
like do you think they'll go do you
think the majority of women who find god
and after they've you know been holes
essentially right do you think that it's
a good maintenance strategy for them to
go to church to find a man
there's there's only gonna be hoes in
church but everyone in church
but no the church
my thing is the church is for sinners
and for those and for the all those
people being all that stuff so
all and then you've come to the lord and
to become new to become perfect so i
don't understand i mean you're looking
for a virgin mary in church you've got
to be quite shocked
but my experience of that
that's afraid enough statement i'm not
going to i hear that my experience at
church is that they don't really they
don't really preach much to do with
the importance of
family and stuff like that a lot of it's
to do with
church well i've been to i've been to a
few churches i don't generally go to
church right but i've generally been to
churches all throughout my my life you
know i mean but i don't i don't see much
uh
preaching about
the importance of
a a man and a woman and the family and
and and sticking in that situation and
so on and so forth so what do they i
miss i missed the day a lot of it's a
lot of what i hear is to do with um
um
which is which is what it should be if
you if you know love god a lot of us do
is
prosperity do you know what i mean
a lot of it's gonna do with prosperity
in itself okay and i think that a lot of
that's to do with just like possible in
church a lot of that's to do with just
keeping people in church because at the
end of the day if you ha um the
collection plate comes around all the
time so i think if you keep people in
church you're gonna make sure that you
know the the church business runs that's
hope dealing in order like but i think
that's what a lot of it is and that's
why you don't see men in church that's
why you don't see many churches at the
end of the day
men
believe it or not actually want family
yeah
they actually want
uh i said this before i said this before
men and women view god differently
right
women are attracted to powerful male
figures that's what they're attracted to
the ultimate powerful male figure is who
we're the church god in the past good
god
and pastor yeah right which is why you
hear women say i don't need no man i've
got jesus
you will never hear a man say i don't
need no woman i got jesus
because it's gay i've never heard
women and women and men see god
differently which is why
you know that's what that's why you find
the majority of women in church because
they're going to see their ultimate man
can i just correct you paul did say in
the bible if you read it i'm saying i'm
saying generally you don't you don't
hear men in the society saying well i
don't need a woman
but those those women are on deceiving
themselves because we all need each
other so it doesn't i don't know why
they're saying that they're probably
hurt no but i'm saying
the casters should tell them to put
themselves on discount you know what i
mean
but that would be against the bible so
he's going to give a counselor
i'm just saying it's also against it's
also it's also it's also against the
bible to be run through and have kids
outside of marriage
it's like but i'm saying this is what
girls do is they'll they'll do these
things and then come to church and try
to raise their value and i'm saying it's
a mating strategy i knew a girl whose
mom did that she had like three kids by
three different dads
and then became born again christian it
was all like yeah but you're supposed to
that's the whole point the whole point
of asking men to wait till i i miss the
days i miss the days i miss the days
when we would deny people from churches
like no no rebecca no rebecca you you've
been run through by the whole football
team no you can't come but that's like
no you're not that's the opposite of the
bible i don't know look at it
i i feel like people should be denied
from churches when you can tell they're
clearly not sorry and they're clearly
not living the worst absolutely the
judge i'm somewhere between i think okay
how are we going to this church
no i'm like cool go to church do your
thing get right with god whatever you've
got to do
but then they become holier than that
and they start to preach that's people
for you like when someone that when when
a hoe gets married or when a girl gets
married she told everyone all the way
she did it the way she did that's how
people are just like they've happened to
use religion at that point to be holding
down but if you were not you were single
now you've got a man you want to preach
every single girl how to get a man these
times that girl don't want to have a man
so just become how people are
interested
and should it be the same for the men
because i personally know someone who is
a man who didn't want to have sex before
married obviously when he became a
christian
and he was trying to put his girl to
that standard as well which obviously
she couldn't meet so should it be to say
that oh because of the man
why couldn't she meet that
because she wasn't a christian that she
wants sex okay yeah he didn't want sex
so he was in the church you're saying
yeah she was outside the church yeah
he wanted to get with him he should find
a virgin girl
right or a asexual like come on man you
can go here
i don't think that's very christian
that people don't have sex like
literally collect there's people there
for everyone just find your tribe find a
person that works for you like clearly
you now become christian she's not
you're being smart there's more women
than man you're banging every day and
then but i mean if men are then cheated
so so what so the men that are cheating
only cheating on the same women then so
if it's how does it what has it work
right but the thing is think about that
that's why baby mothers are fighting
over
fighting with each other because the
same men are breeding the same women
yeah those top guys are breeding ask a
guy
if he's got more than one baby mother if
he's got a child he's probably got two
maybe three
so these women who know these guys are
like this keep choosing this guy to
breed with so then they start arguing
like they always argue monsters
that's i don't well you guys are saying
women are dum-dums you said it yeah i
can't i can say that because i mean we
talk about women women have both way
fathers
like why would you beat number five sis
why would would you number three because
they're thinking emotionally well thank
you because he's shown that he can
provide yeah it's
it's about biologically it's
it's a attraction cue
to know to know that he's taking care of
different
baby mothers on top of that they can get
a check okay you're incentivized i think
a lot of things to do with the check but
then to be honest with you if i meet a
guy who's got five kids i'd be like wow
what does that thing do because you got
five kids but that's as far as it's
gonna go because come on i'm not gonna
be number six but let's face it if you
got sick well you're curious
oh come on i protect myself but come on
you've done enough like you must be
something good down there like you know
what i'm not i was fine with you as well
i quite like i've i met a girl i know of
a girl that she is in her prime as a
female at a certain age as a woman yeah
as a woman right and she met a guy who's
in his 40s or going towards there and
she started finding out things as they
were dating about baby num mama number
one then there's a number two
and she's in it like
deep in it she didn't ask about
questions
maybe maybe not but more so than
anything
when coming to her male friends about it
she she was told
we can tell this guy
has he's done life
that guy is like you know what i mean
and like she didn't want to listen she
was happy in it and then when she
started uncovering all these things
she's too far deep in it
women know yeah they don't get fbi
friends they're attracted to it
um i have a question that someone put in
the super chat
um it's a little different than the
church topic but
if um if our nation was in wartime do
you they really think men do they think
men would really sign up to protect
their nation and women based on how they
are mistreated demonized and not
appreciated
could you say that again please yeah if
our nation was in wartime do you think
that men would sign up to protect their
nation and women based on how they are
mistreated demonized and not appreciated
today if we yeah
well i think most yeah most men are
overweight too so i think we're in
trouble next war i think men
i think the men of nowadays are the
softest yeah i agree you know a little
more effeminate i don't know what china
and russia must be looking at us like
yeah
they must be laughing like these are the
guys that you got yeah they do you know
what i mean they don't care they're not
scared they don't know the world is not
scared not when guys are dying their
hair
green and put in saying i'm asexual and
i'm non-binary yeah it's like asexuals
don't want to have sex doesn't mean
yeah what what guy's saying that
no no some people actually don't want to
have sex
a lot of christian men are celebrating
yeah but that's not because they don't
want to it's because they understand
that in order to the priests
huh like the priests isn't the father's
are they not selling but that's not
someone signing up to go to war
he's saying like what's what's he
men are treated as disposable like women
are not good to men in this society and
one out of three men haven't had sex in
the past year and historically men
became for women so they would become
something because they were motivated to
provide for their family
yeah but now they have no woman to
provide for so they're addicted to corn
and video games because they they're
hopeless because nowadays the average
woman doesn't look at the average man
because the dating market is so inflated
because of birth control that we're
sleeping with a smaller and smaller and
smaller percentage of guys you want a
guy that's over six foot fifteen percent
of guys you want a guy that's in the top
half of attraction cut it in half you
want a guy that's in the top half of
income cut that in half
and so
dating app data shows that we swipe
between five to twenty percent of the
time up they get eighty percent of the
matches
and so it's like these guys have no
purpose
so what why are they going to fight for
our country i would say for society to
survive men have to have a purpose
if men feel like in the society they
don't have a purpose i think you are
going to see the decline of
the west the women have to make you make
that purpose for men that do we have to
make you have but
but that's what we needed for you guys
have a purpose but the to some degree
yeah yeah but i also i also believe that
men are distracted more nowadays there's
more distractions literally they've got
grown ass men playing computer games
every single [ __ ] day sorry in my
language but it's just like
really like is this your purpose like
you're gonna just play games all day
like where's the purpose all day well
and then and
and the problem is that
women like the average woman doesn't get
with the average guy because she's
sleeping with the top guy that's never
going to wife her
and so and and
and typically before we had to
prioritize other things outside of looks
like we had to otherwise we'd get
pregnant by by the chad right and he's
going to leave because you know he gets
all the women he's not going to provide
so we had to prioritize a provider but
with birth control it allows us to sleep
with the smaller and smaller percentage
of men
and not prioritize the other side of it
and then you know we roll up at 30 35
you know running out of time to have
kids saying take me now
and it's like to the average guy
yeah like we could and we deny them in
our 20 this is what men are complaining
about average guy
the average guy was that dude at school
that you were at school with that you
know that dude i know the average guy
but i'm saying the average guy now 45 45
45k average looking yeah yeah so what
i'm saying is every time so whenever so
when the girl's been ran through popping
her pills and she goes back to the
average guy is the average guy taking
her
a lot a lot of the time yeah what's the
problem because they've got no other
options what's the issue what are we
going to get okay
okay because the issue the issue is that
it only benefits women and so there's a
large there's a large there's a there's
a large portion of men that are very
frustrated because they think that the
woman wants to marry them they think the
woman is excited to be with them when
really she misses her her ex from like
three x's ago they get married she gets
the kids she wants then she starts being
a thought again like sierra
right
or or she stops having sex with him
again you didn't see i mean as a mother
and a wife you're going to be twerking
on top of a car
her husband is happy and he's working
but but the point is see it's this is
funny it's like women always excuse
women it's bad behavior you can't come
out
just you're you're in the church you
really think that's acceptable i
probably don't think that okay okay so
then don't excuse it that's excuse me
the same her husband knew where she came
from
yeah we're talking about her behavior
it's always a butt and then the men
allow it this is the same argument she's
been the same from the does she have a
chance yeah she's she
claimed
she claimed she claimed she claimed
uh russell wilson and then you can kind
of see her sliding back to actually wait
wait yeah she claimed she claimed to
have changed
when she was about to get married so she
waited till she was married to have sex
yeah i used sierra as an example because
it's a perfect example of what happens
all the time
in a celebrity she dates the future she
dates the bad boys then she's thinking
hmm i need to get married soon i'm
running out of time let me say i've
gotten right with god same thing with
megan good i've gotten right with god
so i can get a husband the husband
thinks she's changed when really she
feels like she's settling for him
and she really wants the guy from the
past and you can see this because she
doesn't respect him enough to not twerk
on a car
like she doesn't like whereas the other
guy like the other would have been like
what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah and
it's it's on the guys too because they
allow it like i'm with you russell but
but
yeah but the point is that she's
disrespecting him because she doesn't
think that that's the best she could
have done she doesn't view him
as
like meaning women don't respect guys
like that
they they'll say it but in their actions
you'll see whether or not they respect
guys like that see there's a little bit
okay
there are certain women that when they
get with a guy you know that she
respects him and she would never do half
of the things that she would do even
with the other guy that you've seen her
with because she doesn't respect that
guy she's afraid to lose him right and
that's that's how you can tell because
like she's doing all this wild [ __ ]
she's not afraid to lose him no
just like some guys some guys some guys
don't cheat because they're afraid to
lose the girl but i think all those
standards from like since we're talking
about sarah i think all those standards
was more from russell like he was the
one that wanted to wait till marriage
and she just went onto his page because
she liked him yeah so he thought she was
getting on his program and she was it
was just an act so what are they getting
divorced that what's happening no
they're not getting divorced yeah russ
russell i don't know she was actually
russell wilson's simp yeah
it's the same thing with will smith
yeah like she she dates tupac
and continuously talks about him to the
point where her own daughter is writing
a letter to her
like that's i mean is she afraid to lose
will i mean this is in this if this is
happening to celebrities the top men
that women like i would they will like i
think everyone in this room would date
will smith right i wouldn't
i have my mind
okay but you understand what i'm saying
this is happening to top guys what does
that mean for the average guy and so
these guys get married at 30 thinking
that this girl is excited to be with
them but she's not
she just wants kids she wants kids in a
bit a element of safety yeah but then
there's some i mean i mean maybe if for
the for the for the hose yeah but then
i don't i don't think a lot of girls are
out here hurrying around and being run
through i think most girls
unless they're lying but i think most
girls are you know trying to keep the
body count down and find that man so i
think if you if you're not a hoe and you
marry someone i don't i don't i think it
depends if you're already like okay
whatever then if that was the case then
you'd find more uh women in relation
okay so i i pulled i pulled i pulled my
audience and i said what do you think
the average body count is for a 20 year
old woman in 2022
yeah the the highest answer was 10 to 20
for a 20 year old woman 20 years of age
yeah and uh in the uk
oh i
people are from all over the u.s
no
the audience is mixed
what's the average body count of a 25
year old woman um
45 percent said over 20.
and then i said what do you think the
average body count is a third of the
average body count of a 30 year old
woman is in 2022. 34 said 30 plus
so if women are keeping it low i i think
the men would
would agree
but they're not like
i would say low is less than five
because when you when you look at when
you look at bonding statistics like like
that's when it switches for women so the
women answer that or men answer the poll
or anyone anyone answered yeah both men
and women oh okay so
yeah it's it's both it's both and so
like i would say under five would be low
based on data because like women lose
their
you start to see repercussions for
sleeping around after five partners
because the average like the average
if a woman gets married and she's only
had sex with one person that she has an
80 chance of a happy marriage if she
slept with more than five it goes down
to 25 so that's when you start to see
the repercussions so like women aren't
keeping their body counts low
and plus this is one of the reasons why
we know why women lie about their body
count
a man a man will promote his body count
a woman will lie about her
but can i ask is there anything
different like between say a woman today
and a woman
let's say in the 50s like
psychologically it like is there any
loads yeah there must have been because
there's less issues of shame kill
societal expectations the risk of
pregnancy no so what i'm sorry let me
explain that if you brought a 1950s
woman into today's society
would she not behave the same way as the
women behave today she would like women
in the 1950s had cookbooks they were
taught they needed men and they worked
to get a man where women today just
exist they're told not to cook
i don't cook i don't clean that that's
like like our grandparents worked
through how many women like our
grandparents worked through cheating
like there are so many stories they they
they were there in it through thick and
thin where women modern women first sign
of cheating they leave it could be one
time thing he could bring it to you
she's leaving she's out and she's taking
half
1950s he could have a whole side check
across town she's working it out with
her husband it was just a different i'm
not saying
it was it was women had consequences
back then so they acted accordingly
nowadays we took away all the
consequences from women so they act
accordingly but this is the thing like
you keep saying we
whereas
i i give men like the commendation when
i know it's men who have done this like
it's men who
basically built our nation who fought
for us
it is men if we are going to be honest
it is men who are in power and so at the
same time very small percentage that's
not necessarily true women make 70 to 80
of consumer buying decisions so you
can't necessarily say that we're not in
power a very small right i mean like it
makes the laws like in government
right but women vote
and women and women are like they win
elections there's more women than men
and if they're
and if you're you're saying men are the
ones in power it's a very small
percentage of men that you're talking
about you're talking about like one
percent
of the world's population saying oh men
are in power it's like there's one
percent of like the population that are
in power and they they happen to be men
but it doesn't mean
men in general are like that are in
power no no i'm not saying that i'm just
saying those specific elite men are the
ones who are actually setting
society but the way you guys have
explained it they're setting it based on
what um can keep them in power which is
basically women is yeah how you guys
yeah yeah yes
because i mean how did they get into
power they sold a lot of [ __ ]
like so i'm thinking of like jeff bezos
mark zuckerberg they had to
they had to get used women to get there
basically i want to say you sell to
women statistic for consumer debt what
percentage of a consumer did do women um
they own two i think it's two thirds
consumer debt
so even though we make less money we
spend more
baby shopping and i think this all the
time because there will be girls that i
know make less than me and i'm like how
are you buying all this [ __ ] i'm like
because i can't afford that i don't know
what the hell you're doing
when i was in the relationship pay for
it there was an amazon delivery nearly
every week at the door i was like what
you bought something again
oh but i needed it
i'm gonna read super chats real quick um
guys
sign up for our memberships okay uh the
ten dollar tier you get two vlogs a
month we went out to dinner the other
day ish lost a bat there was some fun
behind-the-scenes action that sounds
weird
now you know what maybe maybe there was
ten dollars a month
five dollars you get to be a part of the
chat we also have a discord at the 10 a
month um tier
um
and guys all super chats are going
towards studio updates if there's
something you think is ugly in the
studio let me know because we can you
know switch it up don't say the people
in the studio oh yeah you can't change
them
[Laughter]
okay um and i think we're getting a
camera for ish saturday so oh wow great
yeah so let's
fasting cures
diseases.com
says men need to not give women a single
men need to not give resources to single
women until they can prov until they
provide children 90 free-to-pay what's
the issue what a see you next tuesday 90
free topay for females if men didn't
want sex how would you all attract them
dub men ish is a red herring um
i don't know right is it something
that's rare a red herring it's not real
like
oh
um kill killer magic that's a sadistic
thing to say with a smile i agree with
pearl's glare abortion is a sadistic
thing to do and it's not a laughing
matter 90 free topay don't let women
teach you the bible remember eve
lawrence black church women 403 on
saturday virgin on sunday
craig w the church doesn't keep women
single being 304 is in their valuable
years along with their unrealistic
standards does 90 free topaz bring back
beauty i don't know if you've ignored my
dm from insta yesterday but it's about
how the fed
sub
subsides the state when they collect
child support
um
yeah if you i don't remember this dm but
just remind me because sometimes i get
lost with all of them um
denier lex ac ten dollars towards
towards a studio water slide your dad
needs to put it together
um tommy um sitting here wondering how
to be a direct two three choice question
is answered by i feel i feel wasn't one
a part of the answer selections nassar
al mulem um got a
flag
people's name okay i don't know
some of these are hard okay
you read them sarah
davey jones come on people um likes are
free it's a good
it's good to have you back pearl hope
you enjoyed yourself nightingale21 i
liked already chris
a hundred dollar super chat let's go
chris is our new stream sponsor um while
i get frustrated with women who argue
with logic like the ones on the couch
i've learned that i would
who argue with logic like the ones on
the couch i've learned that i would not
be able to have so many side chicks
without women like you co-signing the
lies i tell them keep fighting ladies
some of us homemakers rely on you
knight and gail we return we need the
return of the cool auntie but also don't
forget the camera the camera for that
man
brit cormier
make more money how hard can it be there
are only so many jobs that pay 100k some
of those are held by women women want
men who do not cheat only date short
ugly men how hard can that be they're
dead they're the best cheers
that is true and it hurts more because
it's like
you're supposed to cheat you know you're
even ugly like it's just like yeah well
carry on sorry
just wow i think we should round up them
you realize that's probably your level
um
i'm just saying like you can't call the
guy
and you're with him
some girls can be like you know he's not
nice but you know i can i confirm it
listen this is
a woman saying something like that let's
guys know
women's minds are different you're with
a guy you think he's ugly you're like
you can't [ __ ] cheat on me you're
ugly
like is that really how you're thinking
about your man like seriously no no no
no it was just the advice they gave go
for a short ugly man obviously most
women are not going to do that i'm
saying if if they did it it would burn
because you assumed they're five and you
know because you feel like if it's gonna
cheat has to be one percent right so
he's not the one percent he's not on
he's living the average 45k and you're
not six foot but here you are cheating
my guy so you lose so
you look at that guy and you think he
can't exercise his options but you just
said that only one percent main collects
has an option so therefore he should not
be but i'm saying typically typically
when girls say that a guy's ugly like
usually he's not ugly he's usually still
in the top 20 30 percent of that really
yeah oh yeah wow that's a different
would you would you guys agree as guys
like even the girls like guys think
they're above typically i think women
have unrealistic expectations of what
men should look like so yeah probably i
agree
is j house ugly he considers it ugly but
you know it's not just the look you know
i think if
he's got charisma if he's got money
ugly if you've got quiz more money
lifestyle
then that could that that has a massive
effect on it as well
it definitely will 100 yeah for sure
um okay so
nasir watts confessions of a f-boy is
the best book on amazon
fastingcaresdiseases.com can we call in
um not yet hopefully we are trying to
figure it out which one yeah
levy in terms of population of the world
or a country the difference in the
number of men versus women in power is
totally
negligible
um 90 free to pay the weave market is 1
million or a billion
fasting cures diseases men oh that's the
same thing um
yeah i think that's all of them
alrighty then we've we've been on for
like over two hours now
yeah just wow that's crazy that went by
yeah yeah
should we uh round up yeah
yeah we can do that yeah go on um let's
go around this way um
our men
to go back to the original are men
seen
in society are they taken seriously
only a small minority
taken seriously you know on your only
unless
you're perceived to have your value
then yeah and then that's a
relatively small percentage the majority
aren't
um
well yes yes that's yes or no in it so
yeah like right this is why you care
about me um i'll say on a whole
not necessarily no but i think that's
why
if society society doesn't care about
you you care about yourself to get the
help you need that's the that's what
that's just the way that i live my life
personally no one cared about me but
i've got my own healing to sort myself
out the same way if you guys if you
don't cares about you still see yourself
out and be someone and find purpose
that's why i see it
yeah i think the simple and unfortunate
answer is obviously no like um
society has sort of left men behind in
the whole fight for women to become more
equal
and um that is that is a shame however i
feel like the solution isn't to
sort of divide the genders but all see
that we all have our own
role
and um to embrace each other embrace our
what makes us unique and we all need
each other it's not men are bad and
women are bad but it's like we all need
each other
yeah i don't think that um society
really
takes men that seriously or cares that
much and um
i think the main reason is is just due
to the
um
history when it comes to i think
feminism and also the the
again over correction when it comes to
uh
trying to put women
forward they've actually just tried to
instead push women above
so
that comes at the detriment of of men
unfortunately that's that just comes at
the detriment i would i would say
if we were advocating for
feminism as equality
i would be happy to call myself a
feminist but i don't think that's the i
don't think that's what the
uh
that's what's happening at the moment
all right actual equality i'm down for
it
i don't know about anyone else i'm down
for it absolutely okay would you be down
for a woman to be equally drafted
yeah okay into what i'm down for
absolutely not frontline combat yeah why
not yeah geez
your country would lose
yeah but this is the thing more it's at
the end of the day it's about
more people at the end of the day like
israel does it more people isn't it it's
more people women aren't
we're not saying we're not saying that
the men don't men aren't in there we're
saying that it's just more heads just
no i don't think i don't think it is but
then you know if everyone was drafted
and there are sections according to
their skill or obviously
you know
certain things then yeah that will work
um there's one more super chat that says
oh two i guess um biggie fat and ugly as
ever however i stay gucci down to the
socks
still still pulled faith evans before he
passed money matters
and do do women on the panel believe men
and women can truly be equal um no
just yes or no really quick
no
no i said it was gonna happen no okay
any final thoughts sarah um yeah um to
kind of you know reiterate what people
said before i don't think
men's issues are taken that seriously in
society and i do believe that if men are
going to have a space it needs to be
amongst men um i think men need to care
about other men and what other men are
going through hence the suicide rate
being what it is
and i would just say this to the men out
there that actually need help want help
seek it
seek it in a place where you know it's
going to be a safe space and don't let
anybody tell you that your emotion and
your feelings don't matter because they
do
and this has been the gray area today
um but before we go
if you haven't
subscribed
and you've watched two or more of these
videos
then we got beef beef okay beef so do
that right now pearl close and forth um
like the video on your way out guys um
that is the most important metric for
the algorithm is like so if you enjoyed
the stream and you want other people to
see it like the video a like it's free
um follow my instagram just.pearlythings
um follow sarah's channel yes follow my
channel it should be in the description
here i should be linked up um
sara gavi and sara garvey on instagram
yeah he is
he has some great content he um he's
very kind
yeah yeah
it's whatever
um
and on top of that we have the twitch
page to go follow that we're trying to
get to like 500 followers on twitch and
facebook so if you guys could like the
facebook page follow the twitch page and
on twitter um pearly things with a z
subscribe to the channel and we will
talk to you guys next time
[Music]
i'm subscribed
no i said albums